welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and enough is enough who really
created the TVA was it Victor timley a
Kang variant who would later become he
remains maybe not this Victor timely but
like a past one who didn't turn into
pasta or is it Ora Boris OB the OG
lookie season 2 episode 4 has suggested
the origins of the TVA were kind of a
chicken in the egg situation of one
engineer inventor inspiring another
engineer inventor but we're not really
sure who inspired whom first but
ultimately a handshake anointed
partnership through time that includes
an individual defined by his refusal to
take partners that tells us something
I'm going to break down all the evidence
this season of Loki has given us
pointing to the true origin of the TVA
how did it begin and what was it before
it began if you love OB as much as we do
we have an OB inspired shirt design
available at nerd rot. shop that really
is the best way to support what we're
doing here at new rockstars one thing I
found interesting while rewatching the
Loki season 1 finale is that he remains
implicitly takes credit for the TVA but
he never explicitly States for the
record that he built it or he was its
founder like take a look
I
weaponized elith and I ended I ended the
multiversal war once I isolated our
timeline all I have to do is manage the
flow of time and prevent any further
branches hence the TVA hence the
timekeepers in a highly efficient
bureaucracy hence ages and ages of
cosmic Harmony yes he remains takes
credit for managing the flow of time and
preventing any further branches which he
does by ruling and regulating the sacred
timeline by composing new pages from
behind his desk in the Citadel but he
never actually says he was the architect
of the TVA infrastructure he just says
hence the TVA as if to say and obviously
I would need an agency to maintain all
of this for me we should also note that
even this backstory is dishonest because
it leaves out Ren slayer's contribution
which episode four reveals was
significant she was the commander of
this Kang variant's Army and I suspect
the partner who helped him tame elith
because he remains indicated that only
through elath was he able to end the
multiversal war elath was the weapon
that no other Kang variant had episodes
3 and four of Loki suggest that he
remains true origin was not in the 31st
Century as he said all of his other Kang
variants had but really in the 19th
century 1860s Chicago on the sacred
timeline I have speculated that Victor
got there by some other Kang variant
perhaps kidnapping a Kang baby from the
31st century and then hiding him maybe
other babies throughout sacred timeline
history waiting to activate one of them
and this young Victor was activated with
the TVA guide book in episode three our
current Victor time told R Slayer that
the book formed a link between him and
OB this book has defined the course of
my life I like to think of it as a
correspondence between myself and the
Visionary author Ora Boris and then the
two meet in episode 4 and it's wonderful
Ora Boris yeah that's
me you wrote the
TVA handbook well yes I did but I
learned everything I know from a BL
brilliant 19th century inventor in them
Victor timely if he had the resources he
would have been bigger than Einstein
that is interesting how did he get this
knowledge from Victor timley did they
know each other rather than it being an
in-person partnership Obi and timley
could have ever had I think Obie just
came across 19th century archived
research of some historical figure
unappreciated in his time overshadowed
by inventors like Thomas Edison Nicola
Tesla and then after this by thinkers
like Albert Einstein verer Heisenberg J
Robert Oppenheimer but when and where
really did OB come across these writings
what was the state of the TVA was this
when he was already in a fully
functioning TVA and was this TVA doing
something different at that time
unaffected by any possible Kang variant
because I don't think OB has ever left
the TVA like while other TVA Employees
were past variants brought into the TVA
susceptible to memory wipes and pruning
something tells me that that's not the
case for Ora Boris he is part of the TVA
Clockwork in ways that other employees
are not like he's the only one who has
this patch of these three little gears
like I would say Obi actually better
fits the bill of the original he remains
in the comics who was not a Kang variant
he was just an elderly TVA employee the
last TVA employee charged with
monitoring the timekeepers OB just kind
of feels like the old guard doesn't he
hey big news for those of you who
already know and love hunai star rail
it's coming to PS5 with seamless
crossplatform data sync hang on I'm
getting ahead of myself here hunai star
rail in case you weren't aware is the
massive freetop playay space fantasy RPG
from hoyo verse the makers of genin
impact and now you can play anytime any
play from your couch when you're home
and Carry Your save with you in your
pocket when you head out if you haven't
played hunky star rail yet now is the
perfect time to start this game is
gorgeous its endless explanation in
combat with dozens of unique expressive
characters right now hunai is
introducing tobaz and numby as a limited
time five-star character so I might have
a new personal fave it's going to be
hard for me to part with jinglu because
I'm a sucker for a big ass sword honai
star rails also introducing a new plot
line that will take you to bog a city
that that's been called the last Bastion
of mankind against the Eternal freeze
there's so much to do in hunai Star Rail
and if you download it now you can get
50 free stellar Jade using the
redemption code in the description log
in for 7 out of 10 days and you'll also
earn star rail special passes that you
can use to draw jinglu or topaz in this
episode Loki poses the chicken of the
egg question and we kind of end with
Obie coming to this kind of realization
it seems like sir if your work is based
on his work and his work is based on
your work exactly which came first it's
like a snake eating its own tail a snake
eating its own tail is what an Ora Boris
is in mythology he was named after this
concept of what he is he who remains in
other kangs are defined by their
mistrust of Partners but Obie and Victor
seem to truly admire each other I was
living in
your engineering descriptions me the way
you explain the electric bypass system
bypass poetry just poetry and Victor
timley turns sy's head when he does this
Mr Ora Boris if anyone can man it's you
and me he shakes Obie's hand Victor
timley shook off RN slayer's hand when
she tried to form a partnership in
episode 3 we've only really seen Kang
variants do this when they see an equal
like in he remains backstory from the
season 1 finale when they formed initial
Partnerships with each other before
stabbing each other in the back so back
to our question who came first who
invented the TVA well I think we're
really setting ourselves up for failure
to think about this causally like one
thing causing the other I think the TVA
has always existed in some form looping
further and further backward in time for
eternity and these two men when it comes
to the modern TVA and what the modern TV
does really just inspired each other but
the thing is I don't think the TVA was
always like this isn't it interesting
that in episode one Loki time slipped
back to an earlier era in Obie's past
when Obie was not wearing glasses I
think that was an earlier era of the TVA
before Ora Boris had ever heard the name
Victor timley before the Kang War ever
really happened between Victor timley
and Ora Boris only one of them has been
depicted as truly immortal like kangs
seem to be destined to die and to
respawn but OB it seems Never Dies never
gets his memory wiped OB is the constant
Victor and the other kangs are variables
but OB can have new ideas new influences
new memories I believe OB is the
original he who remains the creator of
the architecture of the TVA or at least
its Eternal caretaker but something
changed the Kang multiversal war broke
out and Drew in the TVA it took over
this architecture and repurposed the TVA
from its original function to what it
does now prune and Loom but what was its
original fun function I believe the TVA
was originally designed to let it flow
and to bridge the gaps let me explain
what I mean by this the natural order of
reality is not one pruned timeline the
natural order of reality is a Multiverse
Victor timley even States this my
temporal Loom inverts the temporal decay
of the electricity flowing through it
lowering its
entropy and Gathering it into five
threads
of power entropy is defined as the
measure of disorder in the universe
based on the assumption that due to the
universe rapidly expanding outward and
outward that the universe is just moving
to a state of disorder it's the natural
state of things to be chaotic to be
unruly to be an untamed Multiverse so
the temporal Loom is unnatural it's kind
of like the hydroelectric Dam on a river
or a lake that's not how the water is
supposed to flow the loom disrupts
nature think of ob's or TVA as a network
of bridges some kind of inner Hive or
Matrix designed for the Multiverse to
connect with itself in an orderly and
healthy way Bridges contrastingly I
think the post Kang TVA was turned into
a dam something to stop the flow of
water and turn it into a practical use
to do other things that eventually
deplete freshwater I believe the
original tva's function under aoris was
to maintain and grow a thriving
Multiverse Network to connect variants
with each other to Foster things like a
council of of reads a community center
where variants could just kind of hang
out and do things to enrich the
Multiverse you could say a wholesome
version of what Miguel O'Hara is
claiming he's trying to do I just think
OB was the longtime OG caretaker of this
utopian network but then the kangs went
to war in the 31st century and one of
those kangs altered history with a
variant in the 19th century that ended
up writing some stuff that influenced
Obie into thinking that the right way of
doing things was order order in the form
of one timeline and that's why I think
Sylvie sense something wrong with
Victor's handshake with Ora Boris this
isn't meant to blame OB he's a sweet
nature tinkerer and if not for a Kang
variant influencing his thinking and all
of reality would be in a healthier more
natural state of a Multiverse it
wouldn't view things like incursions as
violent acts but just as a way for
universes to shake each other's hands so
while this relationship is really a
Chicken and the Egg deal where both men
definitely inspired each other I think
OB built the original architecture and
the Kang variants took it over and
retold it and weaponized it so let me
know what you think about this Theory
comment down below with your thoughts
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network and support us by
grabbing some merch at nerd r. shop you
can follow me on all social platforms at
e AOS follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockars for more analys
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
bye oh